bonsoir monsieur giraud bon sens du
client vous avez évalué ce que peut
rapporter justement cette taxe à l'état
c'est pas très élevée quand même à
l'échelle budgétaire du gouvernement
canadien n'ont en effet qu'un qu'on
parle d'un budget dans l'ensemble du
gouvernement qui génère ou qui brassent
autour de 400 milliards de dollars une
taxe qu'on estime qui va rapporter
environ un peu moins de 800 millions de
dollars sur cinq ans c'est pas une
source de revenus majeure pour le
gouvernement lorsqu'on considère
l'ensemble des revenus qui qui affluent
dans les coffres du gouvernement fédéral
en effet alors regardons ce que vous
avez évalué par exemple pour une année
la première année qui serait 2023 24 par
exemple sur les automobiles on irait
chercher 120 millions de dollars sur les
navires les gâte les bateaux 34 millions
les aéronefs 9 millions donc vous vous
arrivez à l'estimation de 163 millions
ça donne quoi de faire c'est exactement
c'est un objectif que le gouvernement
s'est donné lorsqu'il a annoncé cette
mesure c'était de faire payer les gens
qui ont les moyens en bonne partie pour
essayer de récupérer une partie des
revenus qui ont qui ont été qui ont
échappé au fisc ou encore pour essayer
de payer pour l'ensemble des mesures de
l'aco vide qui ont été très très
dispendieuse pour le gouvernement
fédéral donc ça faisait partie d'un
bouquet de mesures qui a été annoncé par
la ministre dans son budget doit 2021 et
ça vise à récupérer des revenus fin que
ça touche à l'ensemble de la population
donc on vise évidemment des gens qui ont
les moyens de se moquer des voitures 100
mille dollars donc monsieur fillion la
rolls royce fallait que vous l'achetiez
à 20 aujourd'hui promise danger la paix
j'ai vraiment raté mon occasion de toute
évidence le menton dans le service sa
vie avec lui récupérer des revenus mais
un enfant touché à l'ensemble la
population à 100 touché à beaucoup de
gens cette estimation vous l'a fondée
sur quelles données comment vous évaluez
les gains on présume que il ya des
commerçants qui vont avoir des pertes et
qui a des voitures ou des certains
produits qui ne se vendront pas
également comment comment fonder votre
six nations pourrait stimuler les
revenus générés par cette action on a
regardé les registre public des
inscriptions d'aéronefs de navires et
les statistiques de ventes des véhicules
de 100000 $ et plus puis pour estimer
l'impact de la taxe sur les ventes des
commerçants pour les bateaux les avions
et les véhicules on a considéré des
impacts de taxes similaires qui ont été
émises en unv ailleurs dans le monde et
l'impact que cela a eu sur les biens de
luxe donc on en arrive à un impact sur
les ventes qui devraient être assez
important donc les ventes de ces biais
de luxe devrait baisser d'environ 15%
sur l'horizon de cinq ans de latex donc
des bars des ventes en baisse d'environ
2 8 milliards de dollars sur cinq ans et
ça va affecter évidemment l'ensemble des
biens mais ça semble affecté
particulièrement les bateaux et c'est
probablement lié au fait de la
géographie du canada et du fait que les
bateaux en ce sens ces reports tous les
jours donc non plus facile d'enregistrer
des bateaux à l'étranger pour éviter la
taxe donc si je comprends bien les
pertes pour les commerçants seront plus
grandes que les gains pour l'état
clairement oui fort probablement essayé
en se basant sur les chiffres de vente
dans d'autres pays qui ont instauré des
tanks semblables et on arriva à ses
estimations la basée sur les expériences
d'autres pays semblables au canada donc
vous avez parlé des bateaux il est
déjà quand même assez fortunés qui
pourrait acheter des bateaux pourrez les
acheter à l'étranger les laisser à
l'étranger il ne serait donc jamais
taxer parce qu'ils seraient pas importés
au canada est-ce que c'est facile de
faire c'est ce que c'est facile de
contourner cette taxe là je suis pas un
expert en navigation n'ayant pas de
bateau moi même est ce qu'on s'est fait
dire par les gens qui connaissent assez
que c'est pas très difficile à la
condition qu'on soit disposé à ne pas
utiliser son bateau train souvent en
eaux canadiennes dans le cas où ce
serait ce serait la situation donc
quelqu'un qui a enregistré son bateau à
l'étranger ils l'utiliseraient assez
souvent
ça serait possible de se faire épingler
par le fisc main si quelqu'un achète un
bateau ils
entreposent s'en sert majoritairement à
l'étranger on peut penser aux états unis
c'est pas très difficile apparemment
d'éviter de payer cette taxe là
évidemment la contrepartie de ce fait
qu'on peut pas s'en servir au canada
autant que si on l'avait achetée et
entreposer ou à marie en eaux
canadiennes très intéressant merci pour
ces explications et cette perspective
monsieur giraud merci bien être et
plaisir au revoir pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne ici et redit